hi i'm elizabeth olsen and this is my
glamour
[Music]
i think the standout moments from
filming juan division we're towards the
beginning we're doing all the interiors
of the sitcom and
specifically there's the third episode
when i'm dressed in the 70s and i'm
pregnant
my water's supposed to break and then
water inside the house was supposed to
pour down on us and we were told it was
going to be
hot water and we could only do it one
take and it was
freezing cold somehow it just cooled off
at that time i don't know what happened
but
they felt so awful but it was so funny
the modern family one was so
fun for me because we were so tired at
that point of shooting
i think it had been like our we finished
three months
of shooting and we were just exhausted
it was before christmas break
and i think i was delusional i started
taking a lot of um
like medicinal mushrooms not like drugs
um like um
chaga and cordyceps and ashwanga for my
energy and for my immune system
because we were so run down and i it was
like i was on
i don't know i've never tried adderall
but i think it feels like that like i
just was
on a different planet
[Music]
oh yeah i had major panic attacks for a
long time in my life it was
um totally debilitating and i was
um living in new york on my own and i
was 22.
i was the type of person though that
like didn't understand anxiety because i
it's just like write a list and check it
off like i didn't realize it was
something that was
um something you could not control and
the issue is the control part
and then i just i just learned a bunch
of brain tricks
from friends who actually went to a
neuropsychiatrist
and and instead of medicating i decided
to do it that way
what i learned with panic attacks is you
have to put your attention
off of whatever's making you spin onto
something else which is literally my
acting school training
where you are supposed to be focused on
the person you're with and not yourself
in the moment you start talking about it
you learn how many people
go through this and especially um
at in their 20s and 30s it's like a
really specific time that
um i've heard stories of lots of women
um having these panic attacks and
everyone just like knows that quietly
and i think now
people aren't
the more representations we have of
different types of women the better i'm
not i'm not a very angry person
i've always really held my ground
um just for some reason i don't know why
i think i was just like
i don't know how i was raised but i
always felt like i could say
no in like any work situation
um if someone was making me feel
uncomfortable and i just feel like
that's what we need
whatever i don't know what it is but
just the power of understanding
that we can we don't have to like
follow suit if it doesn't feel right i
like being easy to work with
um i like i like feeling like a game
player and a team member when it comes
to being on set
but i know when someone makes me feel
uncomfortable
and i won't allow that
to continue and i was like that as a
child though i was like that in school
but the word
no specifically was something that i
remember my sisters isolating
and um and it becoming really empowering
and i think for women it's a really
empowering
word and i think you know it's like just
say no to drugs but like truly like you
can just say no whenever the hell you
want like it's really
a powerful thing and it's empowering to
do it
[Music]
there was a producer that i just um
didn't feel comfortable around
on set when i had certain scenes to do
and so
i asked the director to not have him
there
and um they listened everyone has such
crazy stories to tell and i do and i
think it's every
obviously it's every industry it's
largely in politics also
as we're seeing i think at the end of
the day we just all have to be like
normal people
and be kind like just be normal is one
of my favorite things to say like when
people start getting
bizarre like just be normal like don't
be demanding just be normal like be
respectful
have the conversation and be normal
my first film that i did i was nude and
it's martha martin
marlene and i was also assaulted on
camera
my agent when we were making that
contract she said
if the director can't literally say what
he wants to see on camera
then then he's not comfortable filming
you like that and therefore they don't
deserve to have that part of you on
camera
it's a weird job this job but you have
to write these
um these agreements about nudity
and it's easier when you're the lead and
it's not easy when you're like the extra
in game of thrones
and i think that is where there's real
change being
made and then there's the power dynamic
um of of of male dominance on set
you truly have to take the moment and
say um
i want a sound editor who is a woman
how many are there and sometimes right
now they're all gone
and so then you go okay well who's the
best person for the job
um that that maybe hasn't had an
opportunity yet
that is um potentially a person of color
like you just have to just think outside
the box as a producer and i think
it's really easy and then it creates a
really healthy work atmosphere
there's some sort of association of not
earning something that i think bothered
me at a very young age
and had nothing to do with not being
proud of what my sisters were doing it
had everything to do with my own
insecurities
i did i did think i'm just gonna be
elizabeth chase you know
when i become an actress kind of thing
and um i can't believe i became an
actress
i thought i was going to go like be on
wall street
i don't know what i wanted but at the
end of the day i i love
acting and as much as i go through
this idea of do i really want to do this
job the rest of my life which i probably
won't but um right now it is really
fulfilling and there are times where i
don't find it fulfilling and i think the
parts i don't find fulfilling is the
pressure of platforms
[Music]
my first time looking at instagram and i
was like this is kind of fun like i
think i could
figure out how this is fun and then you
get more people
and then you're like oh this is now i
don't know i'm not having as much fun
and now i'm second guessing everything
and then it's like why am i even trying
to
create a character version of myself and
put it out in the world and
the whole thing just made me
uncomfortable and it's not even like i
was really
uh paying attention to comments or
anything i just felt weird
how it organized my brain like if
something happened in the world i would
say oh do i have to post about this
i think it's very dangerous to think
oh something just happened in the world
i am an entitled
person whose voice must be heard on this
issue
and i just think that is such a
narcissistic viewpoint that we're all
like
we're all a part of like it made us all
like live in this weird
narcissistic cycle i do
think it's important for people who want
to be
voices and have platforms and who care
deeply about
issues to do that
i am terrified of
um that kind of pressure
and so um that's kind of where i was
like oh right so i'm just gonna back up
and like do my
things that that i think are important
for the things that i care about
and um try and be kind and good and
and learn and listen during the pandemic
i was like oh well you know what this
just
is not for me and i and i just got rid
of it and
i will i won't go back no regrets
no i'm never going back to social media
[Music]
catherine hondas was so delicious to
work with and she really was like
we are witches how amazing is that like
we
are these powerful women who um
men are terrified by and
um they had to murder us
because they were so scared of our power
and
um our temptation and um
everything that that is so mysterious
about being a woman
to have this ownership of
witches again is really fun